for the last four summers anita has come
from bulgaria to pick the kent fruit
harvest five months hard graft to
provide for her family but after brexit
and the pandemic there aren't enough
workers like her to bring the crop in
we as as a as a farmer are hugely
passionate about employing local people
and there are many roles and career
opportunities for local people here but
we simply don't have the people coming
forward for the for the jobs the
national farmers union wants the
government to grant covered recovery
visas to help tackle staff shortages
across the food supply chain if you look
at some of our pig members they've got a
huge backup of pigs off on farm at the
moment some 15 000 pigs a week that
should be going through slaughterhouses
aren't being killed because like there
isn't enough butchers to process them
this then has knock-on effects
potentially for welfare and we're seeing
the same within our poultry supply
chains just not enough butchers to work
in the processing plants to cut those
animals what happens on the farm is felt
on the high street major brands like
nando's and kfc have closed restaurants
or cut menus in recent weeks and even
mcdonald's can't restock its milk shakes
thanks in large part to the most salient
shortage of all of the lorry drivers
every sector depends on
the haulage industry says it's facing a
shortfall of up to a hundred thousand
drivers and businesses have pleaded with
ministers to temporarily lift
post-brexit immigration rules to allow
eu workers to come and help keep the
economy moving but this weekend the
business secretary quasi quattang has
said no and he's urged companies to hire
and train british workers instead
retailers say that response will not
help them as they try to stop the shells
for christmas i think that that's a very
poor response to a very urgent situation
i think that there's a massive demand
from uh eu truck drivers um for work and
this country currently needs it
desperately um we are
in a situation where we're facing
shortages of not only goods but when the
goods are now arriving
that we now don't even have the option
to get them delivered a summer of supply
problems is already testing britain's
economic recovery from the pandemic
should it stretch into autumn it may
challenge assumptions about the fruits
of brexit too paul kelso sky news